[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen für heute einmal aus
berlin
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht meine
damen und herren aber ich persönlich bin
ganz froh dass ich in der schweiz lebe
und irgendwie auch stolz auf unser land
nicht auf den käse nicht auf die uhren
oder die schokolade sondern auch etwas
viel wichtigeres nämlich auf unsere
demokratie
mein heutiger gast aber sieht das ganz
anders
jason brennen möchte die demokratie
nämlich gerne abschaffen und stattdessen
eine herrschaft der experten einrichten
er findet nämlich wir sind zu doof für
die demokratie herr brennan herzlich
willkommen und dankte für die einladung
gehen sie eigentlich noch wählen ja ja
ja
obwohl sie in ihrem buch schreiben dass
eine stimme überhaupt keinen unterschied
macht richtig
ein sinnvoller grund an die urne zu
gehen ist er glaube man könne den
ausgang der wahlen mitbestimmen aber wir
tun vieles weil wir gerne
gemeinschaftlich handeln
jedes jahr findet der anlass riet von
record stadt an den millionen menschen
am selben tag das gleiche buch wie ihre
kinder lesen
daran beteiligen sich viele weil sie
gerne dinge gemeinsam mit anderen tun
wohl wissend dass der jahresrekord nicht
von ihrer beteiligung abhängt ich
besuche auch hier und da ein rockkonzert
einfach wegen der gemeinschaft wir
nehmen oft an gemeinschaft anlässen teil
obwohl unser individueller beitrag wenig
bewirkt in gewisser hinsicht liste
wählen wie steuern bezahlen damit trägt
man als individuum zum gemeinwohl bei es
ist gut wenn das viele tun und warum
sollte man nicht wenn es so einfach ist
sie sind ja philosoph und professor an
der business school der georgetown
university in washington dc ein kluger
kopf also waren sie auch schon mal
inhaltlich überfordert bei einer wahl
wie ich bin zweck pessimist und daher
vom ausgang der wahlen selten überrascht
deshalb ist meine antwort nein stimmen
aber viele sachen ab und es gibt
abstimmungen zuletzt jetzt die
abstimmung über die eu sr3 die
unternehmenssteuerreform
da waren viele auch überfordern und
wussten nicht genau warum geht es da
eigentlich
und sie unterscheiden die in ihrem neuen
buch das jetzt auf deutsch erschienen
ist gegen demokratie unterscheiden sie
zwischen grob gesagt drei typen von
wählern und das eine das sind die
hobbits die sind unpolitisch musste sich
dann die kollegen interessiert sich für
politik sind fanatisch und dann die
vulkanier diesen rational und sehr gut
informiert die letzten aus dem film star
trek und die hobbys kennen wir aus dem
film herr der ringe was hat es mit
dieser dreiteilung auf sich wenn sie
herr der ringe gesehen oder gelesen
haben wissen sie dass sich die hobbits
nicht für die welt oder für abenteuer
interessieren sie denken wann es erste
und zweite frühstück und das mittagessen
und wollen pfeife rauchen auf die
politik übertragen sind das die
typischen nichtwähler in einer modernen
demokratie
sie bleiben am liebsten zu hause sind
meist schlecht informiert haben kaum
interesse an der politik und keine
starke oder feste meinung wenn sie schon
mal an einem fußballspiel in einem
fußballbegeisterten land außerhalb der
usa waren wissen sie dass die fans
unglaublich viel vom sport verstehen
aber sehr voreingenommen auf das
reagieren was sie sehen entscheidet der
schiedsrichter gegen ihr team liegt
natürlich falsch entscheidet ihr
zugunsten ihres teams hatte recht
übertragen auf die politik ist dass der
typische wähler in einer modernen
demokratie
er ist meist recht gut informiert nimmt
aber informationen sehr voreingenommen
auf alles was seine vorgefasste meinung
bestätigt findet ihr korrekt alles was
seiner ansicht widerspricht ist falsch
reagiert oft angriffig und gehässig
gegenüber andersdenkenden politischen
gruppen der vulkanier ist die ideale ich
bin kein vulkan
ich weiß auch nicht ob es überhaupt
welche gibt ich bringe sie aus folgendem
grund ins spiel wenn sich gewisse leute
für die demokratie einsetzten gehen sie
davon aus dass wir uns wie vulkane
verhalten das heißt wie akademische
unvoreingenommene denke aber das tun wir
nicht
eine demokratie ist also die welt der
hobbits und hole
lassen sie uns am anfang ein bisschen
über die hooligans sprechen also
politisch interessierte die alle
irgendwie sehr parteiisch sind nahezu
fanatisch und ein verzerrtes bild haben
hat sich dieses phänomen verstärkt mit
den sozialen medien wie facebook und
twitter usw
mit diesem phänomen der der der blasen
der bus in denen man sich bewegt ja das
ist tatsächlich so
ich will nicht pessimistisch sein wie so
viele und sagen es werde immer schlimmer
obwohl es nicht stimmt aber in diesem
punkt sprechen die daten dafür fragte
man vor 40 50 jahren in einer modernen
demokratie zum beispiel einen
christdemokraten würden sie mit einer
frau ausgehen die einer anderen partei
angehört dies die antwort meist klar
kein problem
damals hatte man freunde die eine andere
ideologie vertraten
heute leben die bürger in modernen
demokratien dort wo die nachbarn ihre
ideologischen ansichten teilen und die
gleiche partei wählen und sie suchen
sich ihre freunde entsprechend aus
ähnlich selektieren wir die nachrichten
wir haben eine große medienauswahl und
entscheiden uns für das medium das
bestätigt was wir glauben andere medien
konsultieren wir nicht ja psychologisch
funktioniert die politik tatsächlich
ähnlich wie früher die religionen wir
betrachten einander als ungläubiger
eines meiner bevorzugten bücher zu
diesem thema außer meinem natürlich ist
hering die arbeit der
politikwissenschaftlerin dajana maz
darin fragt sie leute in einer studie
sie vertreten eine spezifische ideologie
können sie mir erklären warum jemand
eine andere ideologie haben könnte als
sie wenn die befragte person den grund
nennen kann und die ideologie der
andersdenkenden genau und sorgfältig
beschreibt ist es wahrscheinlich dass
sie nicht wählen geht politisch nicht
aktiv ist und zu hause bleibt
oft lautet aber die antwort die anderen
teilen meine ansichten nicht weil sie
dumm und böse sind viele denken so und
zwar weltweit
und tendenziell gehen diese leute immer
an die urne spendengeld für politische
zwecke und engagieren sich für
politische anliegen das heißt nur die
tief gläubigen beteiligen sich an die
politik was tut man dagegen was tut man
gegen diese hooligans oder anders
gefragt wie lernt man diese kompetenz
der perspektiven übernahme dass man sich
in die gegenposition hineinversetzen
kann die argumente kennt und dann aber
trotzdem wählen geht auf persönlicher
ebene können die medien konsultieren die
nicht unsere meinung vertreten
wir können zeitungen lesen oder
nachrichten schauen die nicht unser
weltbild widerspiegeln und mit leuten
sprechen die anders denken als wir
dabei sollte man eher zu hören als die
anderen mit seinen argumenten in die
ecke zu treiben als college professor
tue ich das ständig im bereich in dem
ich arbeite könnte ich zum beispiel eine
philosophische abhandlung darüber
schreiben dass ich ein glas wasser in
die hand halte und das publikum zu
beweisen versucht dass dies nicht stimmt
so funktioniert philosophie
ich bin also ständig mit gegenteiligen
ansichten konfrontieren und wie kann man
jetzt diese diese verzerrung die die
hooligans haben die ganze welt in ihren
licht gesehen was kann man konkret
dagegen tun gegen diese art dass wir mit
unserer gruppe entscheiden gegen die
anderen vielleicht nur diese belege
annehmen die zu unserem weltbild passen
wie man das im alltag persönlich können
sie das trainieren aber auf kollektiver
ebene sehe ich ehrlich gesagt keine
lösung für dieses problem viele
philosophen und theoretiker die moderne
demokratie geschrieben haben sind der
ansicht die bürger verhalten sich zwar
wie hooligans aber wenn wir sie dazu
bringen miteinander zu reden und zu
verhandeln wenn sie an moderierten
anlässen zu gewissen themen teilnehmen
können sie lernen sorgfältig zu
argumentieren und sich zu einigen
doch wissenschaftler die sich seit 30
jahren damit beschäftigen und solche
experimente durchgeführt haben erzielten
praktisch nur negative resultate
wir sollten uns also nicht fragen wie
wir das problem lösen können die frage
ist vielmehr wie können wir bessere
regierungsentscheidungen erzielen wenn
sich das verhalten der bürger nicht
ändern lässt
lassen sie uns über das später noch
sprechen über diese der operative
demokratie als die gerade schlagen die
verständigung im kleinen zusammen ich
möchte mit ihnen geld noch über die
erste gruppe sprechen über die hobbits
die machen nämlich ungefähr die hälfte
der bevölkerung aus sagen sie also diese
politisch uninformierten und nach wissen
um interessierten was muss man denn
eigentlich wissen und kompetent wählen
zu können um kompetent verhängen zu
können ist es nützlich zu wissen wer die
kandidaten sind und welche parteien
existieren
es ist erstaunlich wie wenig die leute
in gewissen ländern darüber bescheid
wissen
in den usa kann die mehrzahl der bürger
ihrem kongressabgeordneten in einem
multiple choice test nicht bestimmen
man nennt ihnen drei namen und fragt sie
wer vertritt sie im kongress sie wissen
es nicht
die meisten wissen nicht einmal welche
partei den kongress dominiert sie wissen
nur gerade welcher partei der präsident
angehört
die schweiz ist da besser aber viele
andere moderne demokratien schneiden
weniger gut ab doch auch wenn man anders
als die meisten bürger die kandidaten
kennt und weiß für welche ansichten und
welche politik sie einstehen ist man
damit noch kein guter wähler denn man
muss auch wissen was wir resultate diese
kandidaten mit ihrer politik erzielen
könnten
angenommen bei ihnen wurde asthma
diagnostiziert und zwei ärzte wollen sie
mit unterschiedlichen medikamenten
kurieren der eine verschreibt ihm ob
sony die der andere sagt amon und sie
wissen nicht auf wen sie hören sollen um
zu entscheiden welches medikament das
richtige ist müssen sie gewisse
medizinische kenntnisse haben
tatsächlich ist noch sony die mein herz
medikament salbutamol ein mittel gegen
asthma
ähnlich ist es wenn leute finden etwas
läuft schief in der wirtschaft und der
eine will das problem mit der einführung
des freien handels lösen und der andere
mit protektionismus
auch wenn sie wissen um was es geht
müssen sie etwas von ökonomie verstehen
um diese maßnahmen beurteilen zu können
und den meisten leuten fehlt dieses
wissen können was die experten empfehlen
und dann unser wahlverhalten
entsprechend anpassen
das könnten wir aber das tun sie leute
nicht die wirtschaft ist ein gutes
beispiel denn eine überwältigende
mehrheit die linken und der rechten
findet der freie handel ist gut für die
wirtschaft und sogar für die armen er
ist gut für die tram fehler und für die
menschen die abgehängt wurden auch die
meisten wirtschaftsexperten sind diese
an fragt man jedoch die bürger moderner
demokratien wie es um die wirtschaft
steht teilen sie nicht die sicht der
ökonomen sondern vertreten eine
protektionistische
wirtschaftsphilosophie diadem smith 1776
als merkantilismus bezeichnete und
zurückwies er fand diese politik
verfehlt und bewies dass auch und die
letzten jahrhunderte haben gezeigt dass
er recht hat trotzdem ist der typische
bürger einer modernen demokratie nein
merkantilismus bei uns in der schweiz
studien zeigen dass die leute schon
argument basiert abstimmen also sie
prüfen die argumente und viele haben
nach strategien entwickelt zum beispiel
schauen sie was der bundesrat unsere
regierung empfiehlt oder was ihre
präferierte partei empfiehlt und so
weiter was es gibt irgendwie so daumen
regeln und irgendwelche risiken mit
denen man trotzdem gut durchs leben
kommt ohne irgendwie wirtschaft studiert
zu haben
ich denke das ist richtig
häufig werde ich gefragt warum ich in
meinen kritischen abhandlungen über die
demokratie die schweiz oft als ausnahme
darstellen doch es ist nicht klar warum
es bei euch besser funktioniert die
schweizer sind ungewöhnlich gebildete
und rationale bürger bei euch werden
zudem viele politische themen auf
lokaler ebene abgehandelt
dadurch sind die bürger kognitiv weniger
gefordert vielleicht funktioniert es
deshalb in großbritannien den usa und in
deutschland kommen die leute weniger gut
klar mit der politik und es ist nicht
wirklich ersichtlich warum lassen sie
uns ein bisschen über die schweiz
sprechen schweiz gilt vielen als vorbild
in sachen demokratie aber vielleicht
muss man an dieser stelle auch sagen bei
den demokratiebarometer in einem ranking
ist sie gar nicht so gut weil es gibt
vor allem drei dinge erstens ist nicht
klar wie die parteien sich finanzieren
das ist ein bisschen intransparent dann
zum zweiten haben hier kein
verfassungsgericht dass initiativen und
gesetze auf die verfassungsmäßigkeit
prüft und drittens ist der wähleranteil
im vergleich zu anderen ländern sehr
gering
das hat verschiedene gründe aber auch
dass die hürde zu hoch ist
man muss sehr viel verstehen und lesen
um überhaupt die stimme abgeben zu
können
aber der vorteil scheint zu sein
gegenüber den den usa zum beispiel als
die schweiz halt ein konkordanzsystem
hat oder eine konsensdemokratie ist und
der regierung nicht nur eine partei ist
oder zwei sollen die größten 4
die miteinander sprechen müssen und
lösungen aushandeln müssen und wir
schauen uns ganz kurz in einem
einspieler gemeinsam an wie denn
demokratie in der schweiz funktioniert
in der schweiz regieren sieben
bundesräte wer das ist bestimmt die
vereinigte bundesversammlung also
national und ständerat
dabei vergibt das parlament die
regierung sitzen nicht nur an jene
partei die bei den wahlen am meisten
stimmen erhalten hat sondern alle großen
parteien sind an der regierung beteiligt
jede dieser parteien kann einen oder
zwei bundesräte stellen
wir haben eine konkordanz regio
concordia die herzen ich war es nicht
nur der verstand das ist diese
verständigungsbereitschaft über die über
den wahrheitsgehalt ismus hinaus der
spielt eine wichtige rolle spielt gerade
bei uns auf der höchsten regierungsebene
eine wichtige rolle
und das ist glaube ich schon ein
grundsätzlich anderer charakter dann der
der regierung als wenn quasi eben durch
zum teil majorzwahl in den einzelnen
bundesstaaten eine einzige figur gewählt
wird ja verhindert diese art der
konkordanz regierung auch dass so viele
hooligans entstehen und dass wir zwei
parteien halten die gegeneinander
kämpfen
möglich aber es ist nicht sicher
deshalb wird diese frage unter
politikwissenschaftlern viel diskutiert
ich denke alle sind sich einig dass
proporzwahlsystem ist besser als die
majorzwahl die in großbritannien kanada
und den usa angewendet hat zum teil
wegen dir eben gehörten argumente es
sind mehr kandidaten involviert und man
schließt keine politischen standpunkte
aus denn sie haben ihre vertreter und
man muss sich deshalb mit ihnen
auseinandersetzen
andererseits beobachtet man in ländern
mit proportionalen wahl systemen nicht
viel konsens die kleineren parteien
bilden koalitionen
meist hat man schließlich zwei große
super parteien und es kommt zu
differenzen weil eine koalition die
andere überwältigt es ist daher wirklich
erstaunlich dass es in der schweiz so
gut läuft
ich denke niemand versteht das so
richtig andere regierungen mit ähnlichen
systemen funktionieren weniger gut
ein grund könnte sein dass die schweiz
eine optimale größe hat eine million
bewohner sind vielleicht zu wenig 330
millionen womöglich zuviel sieben bis
acht millionen bürger sind eventuell
optimal für eine demokratische
regierungsform
denn wenn man die qualität
demokratischer wahlen mit der größe der
länder vergleicht steigt die qualität
zuerst ein wenig mit der zunahme die
bevölkerung und dann sinkt sie wieder
vielleicht hat die schweiz die ideale
größe nämlich der wähleranteil die
partizipation ist nämlich gar nicht so
groß in der schweiz richtung gesagt habe
und wenn man sich anschaut werden wählen
und abstimmen geht sind dass diejenigen
die eine gute ausbildung haben die
wohlhabend sind auch eher eltern sind
nicht so wie jungen
und damit kommen wir zu einem punkt zu
ihrem neuen buch eigentlich weil
etwas ähnliches fordern sie das ist
eigentlich ziemlich steile these sie
wurden nämlich dass man die herrschaft
des volkes die demokratie abschaffen
sollte
und zumindest experimentieren sollte mit
so etwas wie einer herrschaft der
wissenden diese app ist o kratie nennen
bevor wir darüber diskutieren möchte ich
von ihnen gerne wissen eine persönliche
frage wie kam sah ich zu dieser position
gab seinen wählern scheint der sie
frustriert hat nein den ausschlag dafür
gab keine bestimmte abstimmung
ich bin kein hellseher ich habe nicht
vorhergesagt dass der brechtsche
durchkommt oder jump gewinnt ich wollte
einfach dieser philosophischen frage auf
den grund gehen
der begriff app store partie wurde
geprägt vom philosophen david estland
von der brown university
ich hatte zuvor ein buch geschrieben
über die kriterien die einen guten
wähler ausmachen und über die
persönliche verantwortung informiert zu
sein
ob man informiert wählen geht oder zu
hause bleibt ist beides gleich gut aber
uninformiert wählen zu gehen ist
moralisch schlecht
das widerspricht der verbreiteten
meinung in den usa jeder soll wären
gehen egal was er davon versteht dann
haben mich andere philosophen dazu
gedrängt meine these weiterzuziehen sie
sagten
darum fordern wir nicht angesichts der
empirischen daten über das schlechte
wahl verhalten vieler bürger dass diese
von den wahlen ausgeschlossen werden
oder dass man einen test bestehen muss
um sich als guter wähler auszureisen das
wollte ich philosophisch ausloten
also haben sie die philosophischen
argumente haben sie politisiert
eigentlich richtig manchmal
familienhintergrund hat das nichts zu
tun
lassen sie uns über diese app ist o
kratie ein bisschen sprechen wenn wir
ganz zurück gehen an den anfang der
abendländischen philosophie steht der
plattform und der hat er so etwas
gefordert wie eine philosophen
herrschaft die philosophen die weisen
sollten dann könige werden die gesetze
diktieren weil die wissen ja was gut und
recht ist stellen sie sich das etwas so
vor oder
ich denke aristoteles kommentar dazu war
richtig von philosophen königin regiert
zu werden wäre wunderbar aber wir haben
keine disko part i bedeutet nicht dass
man das regieren ein paar wenigen
experten überlässt
denn wenn man macht auf eine kleine zahl
von leuten konzentriert ist die
versuchung groß diese zwar rational aber
eigennützig anstatt zum wohl aller
auszunehmen
das bringt uns in ein dilemma überlässt
man die macht wenigen experten hat man
eine rationale aber eigennützige
regierung weitet man die macht auch
viele aus entsteht irrationales oder
ignoranz es aber auch altruistisches
verhalten
wünschenswert wäre ein mittelweg das ist
eine überraschende erkenntnis von
politikwissenschaftlern wir denken wir
würden für gerechtigkeit stimmen und
alle anderen nur für ihren geldbeutel
wir finden wir handeln richtig und alle
anderen falsch politikwissenschaftler
haben eingehend untersucht ob eigennutz
das wahlverhalten bestimmt und wie sich
zeigt ist egoismus ein schwacher motor
die meisten bürger stimmen für das was
in ihren augen dem nationalen wohl dient
sie sind also nationalistische soziotop
das ist vielleicht überraschend denn wie
wir wissen sind die menschen im alltag
recht egoistisch sie spenden zum
beispiel nicht gerne sie geben ihr geld
lieber für eine teure schweizer uhr aus
anstatt jemanden vor dem hungertod zu
retten
doch es gilt zu beachten welche faktoren
das wahlverhalten beeinflussen
ihre stimme hat in einer großen wahl
eine verschwindend kleine chance
entscheidend zu sein es macht also
keinen sinn eigennützig zu wählen hätte
mich donald trump vor den jüngsten
wahlen angerufen und gesagt jason
brennen wenn ich gewinne zahle ich ihnen
zehn millionen dollar wohlgemerkt nicht
wenn ich in wählen sondern wenn ihr die
wahl gewinnt unter dieser voraussetzung
hätte ich ein großes interesse an seinem
sieg gehabt aber es wäre kein ansporn
gewesen ihn zu wählen
denn die wahrscheinlichkeit in einem
autounfall auf dem weg zur urne um zu
kommen wäre größer gewesen als die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass meine stimme ihm
zum sieg verholfen hätte
deshalb wählen viele um ihre wünsche zb
nach gerechtigkeit auszudrücken
die wähler sind genügend motiviert aber
nicht genügend informiert jetzt in ihrem
buch machen sie verschiedene ganz
konkrete vorschläge wie sich diese app
ist demokratie diese herrschaft der
wissenden vorstellen vielleicht kann sie
kurz erläutern was so die wichtigsten
modelle seien könnten mit denen wir
ausprobieren können
der ökonom und philosoph john stuart
mill propagierte zb eine art plural
wahlrecht das funktioniert so dass jeder
automatisch eine stimme bekommt doch man
kann mit gewissen qualifikationen wie
einem akademischen grad zusätzliche
stimmen gewinnen
eine qualifikation könnte auch der
staatsbürgerschaft test für immigranten
seien mit ihm die meisten bürger
überfordert sind aber wir den test
besteht bekommt eine zusätzliche stimme
oder wir ein gewisses grundwissen
ausweisen kann
damit sind unbestrittene politische
fakten und nicht akademische theorien
gemeint wird zum beispiel die
arbeitslosenquote kennt bekommt
womöglich eine zusatz stimme ein anderes
system hat die mexikanische philosoph
claudio lopez keller vorgeschlagen
da werden nach dem zufallsprinzip 20.000
bürger auserlesen die wählen dürfen um
sich die nötige kompetenz anzueignen
müssen sie eine ausbildung machen und
dann entscheiden sie die wahl richtig
was genau die ausbildung beinhaltet muss
noch bestimmt werden
lopez guerra meint sie sollten sich im
beratschlagen üben und gewisser
materialien studieren
aber es gibt noch andere möglichkeiten
das system das mich jedoch am meisten
interessiert klingt ziemlich verschroben
ich nenne es regieren durch simuliertes
orad dieses system funktioniert so man
lässt die bürger nicht über eine
bestimmte vorlage abstimmen sondern
sammelt vier arten von informationen
zuerst befragt man sie zu diversen
politischen themen dann eruiert man ihre
demografischen daten
sie weiß oder schwarz reich oder arm
leben sie an die küste oder im
landesinneren
haben sie eine arbeit oder nicht dann
testet man ihre politischen
grundkenntnissen können sie die
arbeitslosenquote auf 5 genau nennen
wissen sie welche partei ihre
legislative kontrolliert kennen sie den
präsidenten und den ministerpräsidenten
ihres landes kennen sie präsidentin
ministerpräsidenten oder kanzler anderer
länder wissen sie ob die verbrechen in
ihrem land zu oder abnehmen
man kann sogar noch eine vierte sparte
hinzufügen das gibt psychologische tests
mit denen man die politischen vorurteile
der bürger prüfen kann
mein lieblingsbeispiel ist ein test von
dann kann einem rechtsprofessor der yale
university
hier stellt den kandidaten eine
mathematische aufgabe er gibt ihnen
fiktive daten zu einer hautcreme studie
und fragt sie wenn das eine reale studie
wäre was würden die daten über die
wirkung dieser hautcreme aussagen
die meisten befragten können dieses
mathematische problem lösen
dann gibt er ihnen eine analoge aufgabe
mit denselben daten und dergleichen
rechenformel diesmal geht es um das
waffengesetz in den usa in dessen
wirkung die probanden beurteilen müssen
und es stellt sich heraus dass die
kandidaten welche die daten bezüglich
der hautcreme richtig interpretiert
haben beim waffengesetz von ihrer
meinung beeinflusst werden
egal ob die daten die wirkung des
gesetzes belegen oder widerlegen
der befragte interpretiert die zahlen
nach seiner überzeugung ob das gesetz
wirke oder nicht
ja sie macht aus uns schlechte rechner
so stark beeinflusst sie uns mit diesen
vier datensammlungen kann man anhand von
einfachen für jede größere zeitung
überprüfbaren statistiken feststellen
was eine demografisch identische
wählerschaft wünschen würde wenn sie
magischerweise keine politischen
vorurteile und ein maximales politisches
wissen hätte
so kann man statistisch feststellen wie
die bürger gewählt hätten wenn sie
besser informiert und weniger
voreingenommen wären mit diesem system
könnte man das wissen dass in der
bevölkerung existiert extrahieren und
bekäme als resultat eine bessere
regierung
sie würden sagen gibt die bürgerinnen
und bürger würden anders wählen wenn sie
mehr wüssten
und das kann sozusagen dieses simulierte
orakel das nachspielen
da kann man herausfinden was die
bevölkerung möchte wenn sie ein bisschen
klüger wäre oder mehr wüsste über die
über wirtschaft und über politik genau
ich bin davon überzeugt weil diese
methode bereits mehrfach in politischen
studien mit unterschiedlichen daten
angewendet wurde
dadurch wissen wir dass informationen
die politischen ansichten die leute
tatsächlich verändert nehmen wir
nochmals die wirtschaft da ich economy
unterrichte bekomme ich oft folgendes zu
hören
im verhältnis zur gesamtbevölkerung sind
mehr ökonomen weiß oder asiatischen
ursprungs
sie sind relativ reich haben bessere
jobs und viele andere vorteile
daher unterstützen ökonomen den freien
handel womöglich weil sie weiß und reich
sind und gute jobs haben und nicht aus
wirtschaftstheoretischen gründen
das ist eine gute sozial
wissenschaftliche hypothese doch sie
wurde getestet und erwies sich als
falsch aufgrund der von uns gesammelten
daten
wir haben viele leute in ihre meinung
gefragt ihre demografischen daten
eingeholt und ihr wissen getestet
bei der auswertung der daten konnten wir
feststellen
inwiefern die demographischen faktoren
der befragten unabhängig von ihrem
wissen beeinflussen was sie unterstützen
und umgekehrt
und es stellte sich heraus dass
informiertheit wichtiger ist als wir
glauben
die daten stammen aus den usa sind aber
wohl auch für andere länder relevant gut
informierte wähler egal welcher partei
sie angehören
und unabhängig von ihren demografischen
daten unterstützen tendenziell dinge wie
die homosexuellen rechte und in freien
handel in der außenpolitik befürworten
sie anstatt militärische interventionen
diplomatische bestrebungen
sie befürworten die bürgerrechte und das
dänische und schweizerische modell einer
starken sozialversicherung kombiniert
mit einem relativ freien anstatt einem
stark reglementierten markt
sie sind für das recht auf abtreibung
trotz moralischer bedenken damit die
frauen nicht kriminalisiert werden sie
wollen das strafmaß für verbrechen
reduzieren und die umwelt schützen
interessanterweise haben schlecht
informierte wähle gegenteiligen
interessen
wir haben viele daten von bürgern
analysiert die das bestätigen und
schließen daraus informationen hat einen
großen einfluss auf das was wir tun und
wollen die liegen ja manchmal irak
einsatz
dann führen für den für die
wirtschaftskrise waren auch experten
verantwortlich das heißt warum weiß man
dass die das viel besser machen ich bin
froh dass sie diese fragen stellen den
ich unterscheide zwischen technokratie
und app ist lukrativ
zieht man wie in vielen demokratien
experten zu rat hat man eine
technokratie in den usa zum beispiel
gibt es zahlreiche mächtige politische
körperschaften und bürokratien an die
der kongress vieles delegiert doch
präsident und kongress haben wenig
kontrolle macht über sie sie können mehr
oder weniger tun was sie wollen und sie
nützen diesen spielraum oft für ihre
eigenen interessen
so ist das us militär bestrebt so viel
geld wie möglich auszugeben um das
budget zu erhöhen
sein höchstes interesse ist nicht die
usa zu beschützen
das ist für mich eine technokratie
episkopat ii ist etwas anderes da haben
nicht experten das sagen es ist ein
system in dem viele wenn nicht sogar
alle bürger wählen
wenn sie diesen tests diesen wissenstest
bestehen nun eine form von piste kratie
ist ein system in dem nur jene wellen
können die einen test bestanden haben
besser wäre jedoch das system von dem
wir vorher gesprochen haben
indem wählen alle bürger aber man
befragt sie und eruiert dann statistisch
was sie wünschen würden wenn sie besser
informiert werden
in jeder app ist lukrativ auch in ihrer
restriktivsten form ist der wähleranteil
also recht hoch nämlich 20 bis 25
prozent und in der weniger restriktiven
form wählen alle aber ihre stimmen
werden gemäss ihrem wissen gewichtet so
verhindert man dass eine kleine gruppe
von experten ihre macht für die eigenen
interessen missbraucht und anderen
schadet in den beispielen von
machtmissbrauch die wir erwähnt haben
profitieren nur wenige nämlich die
experten von ihren entscheidungen und
alle anderen müssen die kosten tragen
mit der visto kratie will man das
verhindern indem man die macht relativ
breit abstützen es gibt ja viele
situation muss ich die experten nicht
einig sind sie sagen jetzt in bestimmten
wichtigen sachen sind sie sich einig
aber es gibt auch viele konflikte viele
unterschiedliche ansichten
und vielleicht ist ja das war vor etwas
wie ein schiedsgericht das dann
entscheidet welcher experte wem man
trauen
ich stimme ihnen zu experten sind sich
nicht in allem einig auch nicht über
dieses buch aber es gibt auch
übereinstimmungen und demokratien
ignorieren oft dass in gewissen fragen
bereits konsens bestünde und weisen
dinge zurück die sozialwissenschaftler
geprüft und einhellig empfohlen haben
aber wir müssen manchmal dinge
entscheiden ohne genau bescheid zu
wissen
vielleicht ist abstimmen eine faire art
das zu tun daher könnte man einen
durchschnittsbürger der wenig über
politik weiß sagen hören sie sich doch
die debatten der experten an und bitten
sie heraus was ihnen am besten
doch so rational denken wählen
schlichtweg nicht sie haben viel eher
eine vorgefasste meinung die vielleicht
sogar genetisch bedingt ist oder sie ist
aus der luft gegriffen und hat keine
grundlage wenn diese leute dann mit
verschiedenen experten konfrontiert sind
hören sie instinktiv auf jene die
bestätigen was sie glauben und
ignorieren die anderen schreiben sie wie
ein hammer ein instrument um die
gesellschaftlichen wie besser zu machen
und ich glaube ich sehe das ein bisschen
anders ich glaube es ist schwer zu sagen
was im politischen richtig und falsch
ist wo wir eigentlich hin steuern und
demokratie scheint mir so etwas zu sein
wie eine biene suchen eine gemeinsame
suche nach dem nach dem richtigen liebe
zusammenleben wollen
und wir hören uns dazu noch mal den
schweizer philosophen france ist schön
waren
das was wir schätzen aber demokratie ist
gerade das ideal eines ergebnisoffenen
verfahren für den fall dass wir
inhaltlich unterschiedlicher meinung
sind und da sind wir normal wenn sie
sehr vielen fragen also man kann sich
auf die inhalte nicht einigen dann
einigt man sich auf ein möglichst
ergebnisoffenes entscheidungsverfahren
und das ist eigentlich das wesentliche
an der demokratie nicht wahr es gibt
dann experten denen man vertraut oder
interessenvertreterin vertreter denen
man vertraut und syrien die die wähler
und rede wir sind nicht orientierungslos
auch bei diesen komplexen fragen denn es
gibt ja dann für die einzelnen
sachfragen experten sind sicher dann
meistens auch nicht einig das ist ja
dann auch das problem
und da ist eigentlich war das stimmvolk
das wahlvolk ist so etwas wie das
schiedsgericht konkurrierender experten
position und dieses schiedsgericht
einfach abzuschaffen
würde ich für falsch halten also da noch
mal diese ansicht mit dem schiedsgericht
wenn sich die experten nicht einig sind
und davor diese idee der dekorativen
demokratie das gemeinsam beratschlagen
es herausfinden diskutieren
argumentieren wo wollen wir hin gehen
weil das ziel ist ja gar nicht klar die
einen wollen mehr freiheit individuelle
freiheit die anderen wollen mehr
gleichheit zum beispiel die einwahl
offenheit integrationspolitik die
anderen wollen eher ein konservativ also
das alte bewahren
was machen sie damit wenn die
zielvorstellung völlig unterschiedlich
sind und ich glaube es gibt da nicht
etwas das richtig ist und etwas falsch
ist
ich glaube wer sich für demokratie
einsetzt muss zugeben dass es ein
richtig und falsch gibt es klingt
seltsam wenn sie sagen es gibt keine
moralischen fakten deshalb brauchen wir
die demokratie wenn man sich für sie
stark macht dann doch wegen der
moralischen tatsache dass allen ein
faires entscheidungsverfahren zusteht
stellen sie sich zudem folgendes
szenario vor in den usa lagern viele
nukleare sprengköpfe die wohl nie zur
anwendung kommen das haben wir satt und
fordern mit einem referendum den
winzigen inselstaat tuvalu zu
bombardieren einfach zum spaß nicht weil
es uns etwas bringt 99,9 prozent stimmen
dafür und nur 0,1 prozent dagegen
unsere bombardieren virtual oder tun
etwas ähnlich schreckliches es wäre
befremdlich zu argumentieren
wir haben fair und demokratisch
entschieden nein es ist falsch da sind
sich wohl die meisten leute eigentlich
gewisse dinge dürfen regierungen nicht
tun auch wenn es demokratisch
entschieden wurde
sie können nicht die sklaverei wieder
einführen aus spaß einem land den krieg
erklären oder die rechte ihrer bürger
verletzen
es gibt grund recht es gibt eine
gerechtigkeit
daher stellt sich die frage in welchem
bereich sind demokratische
entscheidungen legitim
und es gibt noch ein anderes problem mit
diesem demokratie modell
es ist wunderbar aber es entspricht
nicht der realität der demokratischen
politik vielleicht kennen sie das
phänomen der studentenverbindungen an
amerikanischen hochschulen
sie gründen alle auf sehr noblen idealen
die verbindung sigma exelon wer aus
ihren mitgliedern perfekte wohlerzogene
gentlemen machen und hat alle diese
moralischen normen aufgestellt denen die
studenten entsprechen müssen das ist das
ideal und in die realität sind sie
laufende vergewaltigungs fabriken
sie benehmen sich sehr schlecht es
besteht ein missverhältnis zwischen den
wie sie sein sollten und wie sie
tatsächlich sind
ähnlich ist es in der demokratie und ich
lese wie sich philosophen eine gut
funktionierende demokratie vorstellen
klingt es wie die beschreibung der
idealen studentenverbindung in der
realität diskutieren bürger nicht
miteinander sie sind nicht offen für
andere meinungen
sie hören nicht richtig zu und lassen
sich nicht auf verschiedene ideen ein
in einer demokratie geht es nicht so wie
in einem guten vorlesungssaal da
schleudert man sich viel mehr vorurteile
an den kopf ohne sich um die folgen zu
scheren was die delegation die
verständigung angeht und die frage ob
demokratie die bürger eigentlich besser
und informiert da macht es gibt ja auch
studien die zeigen doch es gibt dann
wissensfortschritt es gibt mehr
vertrauen in die regierung wenn man da
muss ich einige meiner kollegen
kritisieren denn als vorbereitung zu
meinem buch las sich alle empirischen
studien über derivative demokratie und
stellte fest die meisten experimente und
studien kommen zum schluss dass
deliberation nicht funktioniert ich
zitiere in meinem buch einige autoren
die alle diesbezüglichen studien
miteinander verglichen
und es zeigte sich der libera tiefe
diskussionen polarisieren die teilnehmer
und machen sie extremer
kasans den nennt dies das eiserne gesetz
der polarisierung allgemein punkten die
teilnehmer mehr mit ihrem aussehen und
ihrem status als mit der qualität ihrer
argumentation grundsätzlich lernen sie
gewisse fakten aber nicht mehr als wenn
sie eine zeitung lesen würden
normalerweise einigen sie sich nicht
kommt es dennoch zum konsens bereuen
hinterher viele dass sie dazu
beigetragen haben sie haben nur
zugestimmt um einen konflikt zu
vermeiden und glauben nicht an das was
sie gesagt haben
die meisten studien sind also negativ
doch weil die leute so sehr wünschen
dass sich die idee liberati wie
demokratie durchsetzt ignorieren sie die
negativen studien und konzentrieren sich
auf die wenigen positiven ich hoffe
daher dass experten wie james fischkind
herausfinden wie die der aktive
demokratie funktionieren kann
denn ich möchte dass sie erfolgreich ist
doch gemäss studien sind die resultate
überwiegend negativ ich finde dieses
buch ersten diese sehr gut geschrieben
das rechne ich ihm hoch an die listen
auch alle gegenargumente hat das ist ja
toll und es kommt in eine zeit wo man
sagen würde
irgendwie ist das zum richtigen
zeitpunkt geschehen mit und mit dem
rexit mit trump sie haben gesagt sie
haben schon früher damit gearbeitet aber
jetzt erleben wir in vielen ländern
europas den usa eine welle des
populismus gegen die erlebten ist so ein
system bis zur partie überhaupt
mehrheitsfähig muss das sein
momentan sicher nicht da erleben wir
eine art anti intellektuelle bewegung
davon zeugt das populäre buch anti
intellektualismus im amerikanischen
leben von richard hofstadter doch
amerikaner waren schon immer gegen
experten und intellektuell ungewöhnlich
ist dass dieses phänomen nun auch in
europa und in kanada auftaucht das in
den usa eben erschienene buch des auf
experten beleuchtet dieses phänomen in
den letzten 20 jahren entstand eine
schlechte form von egalitarismus immer
mehr leute finden meine meinung ist so
gut wie die der anderen egal was ich
denke
erstaunlicherweise betrifft das vor
allem die politik würde ich zu meinem
klempner sagen ich habe keine
entsprechende ausbildung aber ich war
so gut wie sie wie man die sanitären
leitungen im haus verlegt finden das
alle sehr anmaßend geht es aber um
politik wissenschaft oder ähnliche
gebiete finden die leute ich habe zwar
dieses fach nicht studiert und als wenig
darüber aber ich habe meine meinung und
die ist so gut wie die der anderen
ja der populismus nimmt zu und das ist
gefährlich aber im gegensatz zum
klempner muss ich ja sagen in der
demokratie betreffen die regeln die ich
für die ich stimme die ich wähle die
betreffen nicht selbst auch und das ist
doch irgendwie sowas wie eine
legitimation der politiker dass sie eben
das einverständnis der bürger brauchen
damit sie nicht einfach ein arzt kann
auch nicht sagen ich mache jetzt an
ihnen das und dass das ist paternalismus
sondern sie müssten einwilligen sie
müssen ja informiert zustimmen können
ich würde das gerne an aber es stimmt
leider nicht und zwar aus folgendem
grund wenn sie in persönlichen belangen
schlecht entscheiden also zum beispiel
zwei päckchen zigaretten pro tag rauchen
erkranken sie vielleicht an lungenkrebs
aber sie schaden nur sich selber wenn
wir schlecht abstimmen schaden wir nicht
nur uns selber sondern würden als teil
einer minderheit unseren willen den
leuten auf die anders stimmten den
leuten die im land leben aber nicht
abstimmen dürfen und den leuten die
außerhalb des landes leben und davon
betroffen sind
so war niemand außerhalb der usa mit der
wahl von donald trump einverstanden doch
alle sind von unserer entscheidung
getroffen ist zu einem gewissen grad ist
das auch umgekehrt der fall obwohl wir
nicht so stark von der schweizer politik
betroffen sind wir von der
amerikanischen sie waren nicht
einverstanden trotzdem müssen sie mit
unserer entscheidung leben
übrigens wurde das konzept der
konsensdemokratie bereits vom
schottischen philosophen david hume
widerlegt bevor die modernen demokratien
entstanden sind
er sah es als eine art mythos zu glauben
eine demokratie keine konsens basiert
sein willigen sie in eine sache ein sind
sie damit einverstanden wenn sie aktiv
dagegen sind geschieht sie nicht und die
gegenpartei muss ihren teil beisteuern
wenn ich ein williger ihnen diesem stift
abzukaufen und ihnen geld dafür gebe
sie mir den stift geben in
demokratischen entscheidungen finden sie
keines dieser merkmale
man könnte sagen sie stimmen
stillschweigend zu weil sie das land
nicht verlassen
doch das ist kein gutes argument denn
die meisten leute können nicht einfach
legal in ein anderes land ziehen
wer in der europäischen union lebt kann
sich etwas freier bewegen
ich kann als us bürger nicht einfach
nach kanada auswandern
das erlaubt kanada nicht die regierungen
lassen nicht so dass man beliebig
umzieht
auch wenn man aktiv gegen etwas stimmt
ändert das nichts wenn ich in virginia
marihuana rauche und ein polizist mich
dabei erwischt kann ich nicht sagen ich
bin mit dem gesetz nicht einverstanden
anders ist es wenn mich die gitarren
händler anruft und sagt wir möchten
ihnen eine fender gitarre schicken sage
ich nein tut er es nicht
zudem setzt der konsens eine
vereinbarung voraus in der jeder seinen
teil beitragen muss doch die meisten
regierungen fühlen sich dazu nicht
verpflichtet
in den usa zum beispiel hat das höchste
gericht mehrmals entschieden dass die
regierung nicht verpflichtet ist jedes
individuum zu schützen
dazu gibt es einen berühmten fall aus
washington dc eine frau rief die polizei
an bei mir sind zwei einbrecher hätten
sie mich die polizei antwortete sorry
wir sind beschäftigt die frau wurde
vergewaltigt und geschlagen sie
verklagte die polizei und das höchste
gericht befand die regierung hat nur
eine generelle keine individuelle
schutzverpflichtung doch so funktioniert
eine einvernehmliche transaktion nicht
stellen sie sich vor ich gebe meinem
gitarren händler geld für eine gitarre
und seine reaktion wäre
wir schicken ihnen die gitarre nicht
obwohl wir das sonst meistens tun das
ist nicht einvernehmlich damit sage ich
nicht wir sollten anarchisten sein oder
keine regierungen haben ich denke nur
die vorstellung demokratie was ihre auf
konsens stimmt nicht so funktioniert sie
nicht okay aber trotzdem nützt es auch
nichts wenn wir sagen wir machen
die politiker machen das richtige aber
niemand versteht es von der bevölkerung
die wir folgt sozusagen über die köpfe
der bürgerinnen und bürger hinweg da
gibt's auch aufstände und so weiter
irgendwie müssen wir doch das volk und
die bevölkerung informieren und mit
sehen
vielleicht aber vielleicht auch nicht
das ist eine wichtige frage und ich habe
widersprüchliches darüber gelesen
laut dem deutschen soziologen max weber
braucht eine regierung damit sie
funktioniert und stabil ist das
vertrauen der meisten bürger bedingt
dies dass sie glauben ihre regierung sei
demokratisch das ist nicht klar
in gewissen demokratien vertrauen die
bürger ihren regierungen in anderen
nicht nehmen sie singapur
ich weiß nicht ob singapur eine
demokratie ist oder nicht
singapur hat eine sehr technokratisch
und sogar app historische regierung
die meisten bewohner akzeptieren dass
weil es funktioniert sie vertrauen
darauf dass diese leute mehr davon
verstehen als sie und machen mit
anscheinend sie finden wir haben genug
zu essen sind reich und haben ein gutes
leben dann muss es funktionieren
doch es gibt länder deren bewohner auch
genug zu essen haben und reich sind und
die finden es laufe sehr schlecht und
sie geben ihre regierungen die schuld
für dinge die sie gar nicht verantwortet
es ist also nicht klar was legitim ist
die er bis zu kratie oder die demokratie
denn wir politikwissenschaftler wissen
noch nicht was ihre legitimität
begünstigt oder erschwert viele leute
aus der politik zurückziehen würden
vielleicht weniger hobbits aber ganz
viele wenige hooligans aber ganz ganz
viele hobbys die einfach sich nicht für
politik interessieren
wir haben eine frage haben sie bereits
angesprochen warum funktioniert es in
der schweiz so gut obwohl die
stimmbeteiligung in wichtigen nationalen
abstimmungen so tief ist weil nur die am
besten informierten bürger abstimmen
das finde ich ganz gut und entführer
damit manche leute denn in den meisten
demokratien haben politisch engagierte
einen hohen status
doch damit möchte ich aufräumen
ich denke politiker sind nicht mehr als
verwalter des öffentlichen guts ein
politiker ist nicht nobler als ein
klempner
ein automechaniker und es ist in ordnung
dass die meisten leute die politik
bleiben lassen wer politisch aktiv sein
will muss kompetent sein das schuldet er
seinen mitbürgern sonst soll jetzt zu
hause bleiben
wir sagen auch nicht so einem mediziner
egal was sie von chirurgie verstehen sie
müssen diese operationen durchführen
aber aus irgendeinem grund erwarten wir
von den bürgern dass sie einen
kandidaten wählen egal was sie vom
weltgeschehen verstehen auf
individueller ebene schadet das
niemandem aber wenn eine mehrheit von
wählern das tut haben wir als folge eine
schwache regierung mehr kriege eine
schlechte wohlfahrtspolitik bürger
rechtsverletzungen armut usw den
belgischen historiker david von ray
druck der ein buch geschrieben hat gegen
waren
er ist ein verfechter der demokratie
aber er konstatiert auch so etwas wie
eine demokratie müdigkeit und sein
vorschlag ist wir müssen die bürgerinnen
bürger beteiligen aber eben nicht nur
indem sie vertreter bädern ins parlament
sondern eben auch in dem sie selbst
sozusagen ins parlament kommen an dem
wir per los gewisse auswählen und die
haben dann auch nicht dass die die
laster dass sie wiedergewählt werden
wollen sondern sie können politik machen
nachhaltig für das gemeinwohl und für
eine bestimmte zeit und danach sind sie
wieder entlassen kann ihren job
nachgehen was halten sie von dieser idee
das ist eine interessante idee auch die
brite ben saunders und der amerikaner
alex guerrero plädieren für dieses
system die sogenannte de marchi indem
man die regierungsmitglieder per los
ausgewählt das hat sicher vorteile es
gibt weniger missbrauch weil man nicht
weiß wen man beeinflussen kann
dadurch ist lobbying schwieriger die
frage ist aber sind die meisten bürger
genug kompetenz für die regierung
einige nehmen das alte athen als
beispiel wenn es dort funktionierte
warum nicht auch in heutigen regierungen
aber die athena waren ein sonderfall
sie wählten ihre leute aus einer
minderheit aus eine kleine gruppe gut
gebildete athener bürger stellte die
kandidaten in dieser lotterie
es waren leute die ländereien und andere
besitztümer hatten und sich daher zeit
für die politik nehmen konnten
und aus dieser gruppe bestimmte man per
los die regierung doch das athener
modell war nicht demokratisch sondern
eine form von disco kratie wie sie
claudio lopez gerda beschreibt in der
die bürger die per los gewählt wurden
sich auch durch kompetenz auszeichnen
müssen
abgesehen davon ist es eine interessante
idee und ich hoffe dass damit
experimentiert wird
dasselbe gilt für demokratie formen wie
die d-mark oder die sogenannte food
archiv in der entscheidungen mit hilfe
von prognosen märkten getroffen werden
wie die app ist okay sind das relativ
neue ideen wir wissen nicht wie sie
funktionieren
ich finde es wichtig dass man offen ist
da für sie studiert und ausprobiert und
wenn sie im kleinen funktionieren die
versuche ausweitet aber im moment sind
wir mit diesem ruf und meinem und
anderen werken die aus demokratische
indien postulieren in der gleichen
situation wie die demokraten in den 1700
90er jahren
sie argumentierten dass demokratie
besser funktioniere als monarchie
aber sie wussten es nicht da sie keine
erfahrung damit hatte schrieb jemand
1795 die demokratie sei besser als die
monarchie hatte er dafür keine
wirklichen argumente
er konnte sagen die usa sind eine art
von demokratie aber sie übernahmen das
britische system und ersetzten einzig
dem könig mit dem präsidenten sonst war
es genau gleich den amerikanern ging es
denn auch nach der revolution nicht
besser als zuvor
es dauerte lange bis sich wirklich etwas
änderte auch frankreich hat damals die
demokratie ausprobiert und es war ein
totales desaster
doch heute nach mehreren hundert jahren
wissen wir die demokratie funktioniert
insgesamt tatsächlich besser als die
männer
in diesen ideen sind wir also in der
gleichen situation wir können darüber
nachdenken und damit experimentieren
eine app ist kathi das gibt es halt noch
nicht vielleicht mit den athenern und
den griechen vielleicht hat sagt
deswegen funktioniert weil die größe
auch nicht so groß war das waren ja
diese kleinen police die stadtstaaten
und den gedanken bin ich nicht ganz
spannend und auch bei regen kommt es vor
dass man ja nicht alle bürger
miteinander diskutieren es werden zu
viele sondern es kommt auf die richtige
größe drauf an und dass diese
deliberation neben kleinen besser
funktioniert und wir hören uns dazu noch
mal kurz die stimme von rossis schöne
waren das wesentliche demokratie ist aus
den augen verloren gegangenes nämlich
die verständigungsbereitschaft der
bürgern und bürger nicht so sehr ihr
politisches fachwissen ihre
verständigungsbereitschaft ist
eigentlich der sauerstoff der der
demokratie nicht wahr das ist wichtig
manchmal je mehr die leute der liberalen
desto polarisiert wird die gruppe das
stimmt nicht also in mainz dann kann man
das nachweisen
da muss man sich halt die frage stellen
unter welchen bedingungen kommt es zu
diesen polarisierungen wohl nicht ich
glaube wenn man eben nur der linie dann
kann das geschehen wenn man zusammen
handeln muss und die konsequenzen des
hand und selber tragen muss dann ist
wohl die kompromissfindung er wieder
begünstigt wenn wir uns immer nur
theoretisch der libera tief und lauerten
dann können wir uns auseinander
dividieren wenn wir gemeinsam
entscheiden müssen und anderen dann ist
es eigentlich besser und das ist es auch
was was geschieht in der lokalpolitik
ist ja interessant wie die oft wie die
ideologischen spaltungen gerade in der
lokalpolitik oft eine geringere rolle
spielen weil da sind die leute näher
dran am entscheiden am handeln und am
leben mit den konsequenzen der eigenen
entscheidungen nicht weil ja was halten
sie davon
ich gebe ihm recht ich denke demokratie
funktioniert am besten in kleinen auf
lokaler ebene aus den von ihm genannten
gründen
wenn wir entscheiden ob wir die
hauptstraße neu teeren oder die schulen
verbessern sollten bin ich direkt von
den folgen dieser entscheidungen
betroffen daher neige ich eher dazu
rational zu entscheiden
und genau darüber nachzudenken wir
zahlen ja auch steuern dafür
auf nationaler ebene geht es mehr um
dinge wie die luftverschmutzung
da ist es leichter irgendeine
entscheidung zu treffen weil man die
folgen oft gar nicht sieht von dem
verursachten konsequenzen sind eher
andere als sie selber betroffen
daher funktioniert die direkte
demokratie besser im kleinen auf
nationaler ebene ist dann mehr
expertenwissen nötig und es ist
schwieriger sich das ohne entsprechende
bildung anzueignen
gerade diese diese bildung die gehört
irgendwie auch zu einer demokratie weil
demokratie ist mehr als nur wählen und
abstimmen sondern man brachte ihn
politische bildung an den schulen man
braucht unabhängige medien die gut
informieren so was wie aufklärung hat
und ohne das kann demokratie
wahrscheinlich gar nicht funktionieren
da ich bin pädagoge ich liebe die
geisteswissenschaften und lese gern
ungewöhnliche bücher aber ich bin auch
ein ungewöhnlicher mensch und obwohl ich
pädagoge bin muss ich zugeben es ist
nicht klar ob die bildung insbesondere
die politische etwas bringt es ist eher
so dass die staatsbürgerliche bildung in
den usa ein kompletter misserfolg ist
aus folgendem grund die informations
ökonomie lässt sich auf einen satz
reduzieren
man nimmt informationen auf und behält
sie wenn man sie interessant oder
nützlich findet das problem ist die
meisten leute bekommen ihre
staatsbürgerliche bildung in der primar-
und sekundarschule
doch wenn sie hinterher getestet werden
haben sie das meiste vergessen
durchschnittlich behalten sie nur
zwanzig prozent von dem was sie in der
schule gelernt haben und zwar weil es
ihnen nichts nützt
ich übersetze lateinische gedichte nicht
mehr so gut wie vor fünfzehn jahren weil
ich es nicht mehr tun muss
ich studierte chemie im hauptfach und
habe dennoch fast alles vergessen weil
ich es in meiner arbeit nicht brauche
ich weiß nur das was ich in meinem job
anwender so geht es auch den meisten
bürgern von ihrer staatsbürgerlichen
erziehung bleibt verschwindend wenig
übrig gleichwohl gilt je gebildeter die
bevölkerung ist desto mehr politisches
wissen bleibt
hängen grundsätzlich behält man 20
prozent von gelernten wer also viel
gelernt hat weiß auch mehr
wir wären froh wenn bildung die lösung
wäre aber es ist nicht klar ob das
stimmt vielleicht ist die die
information dass der wissensstand wir
gar nicht so entscheiden weil er hängt
also schon entscheiden aber hängt vor
allem auch wie sie im buch schreiben vom
interesse
das fand ich ganz spannend also nicht
wie viele ausbildung nicht gemacht habe
ob ich einen universitätsabschluss habe
oder nicht sollen wie interessiert ich
bin an politik und wie kann man dieses
interesse wecken in der bevölkerung
das ist eine gute frage wie sie gesagt
haben die bildung allein ist kein garant
für politisches wissen
das pew forschungszentrum macht
erhebungen darüber wie viel die
amerikaner über grundlegende politische
dinge wissen wie sich zeigt beantworten
bürger mit einem bachelor-abschluss nur
eine frage mehr richtig als solche mit
einem sekundar schulabschluss wer sich
aber für politik interessiert
beantwortet acht fragen zusätzlich
richtig unabhängig von der bildung
doch wie weckt man dieses interesse das
ist ein problem denn die meisten filmen
politik nicht interessant so wie viele
chemie oder physik und interessant
finden und die wirklich interessierten
verfallen dem siebten denken und sehen
alle anderen nur als feinde
dieses interesse kann also auch
gefährlich sein denn es geht mit
vorurteilen einher
alle anderen werden zu feinden und ich
habe immer recht
es ist also nicht klar ob so viel
interesse wünschenswert ist und die
frage bleibt wie macht man
intellektuelle ideen attraktiv für die
massen
viele tun das indem sie neue bücher in
neuen formaten schreiben richtig grill
rosa mit provokativen titel am ende der
[Musik]
vulkanier vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
jetzt gleich folgt sternstunde kunst mit
dem dokumentarfilm achtung brut einer
kunst die boomt und berührt
wie das geht sehen sie selbst ich
wünsche ihnen einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]